Heute nacht um 132 wird eine falcon 9 rakete mit einer ganz besonderen fracht gestartet eine neue phase der alien suche startet
wenn der nasa satellit ins all geschickte test steht dabei für
trading exoplanet service satellite also satellit zur untersuchung vorbeiziehen der
exoplaneten sein vorgänger keppler über den aber ja oft berichtet der geht in rente und es wird ihn ersetzen mit viel spannenderen leistungsdaten
Ja, also ob er jetzt schneller aliens finden werden unser thema jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Der weltraum teleskop kepler geht in rente, im geht der treibstoff
Aus um sich korrekt auf die zu untersuchenden sterne auszurichten und in andere richtungen wiederum auf die erde um die gewonnenen daten
zu übermitteln kepler hat bis heute
unglaubliches geleistet die entdeckung der mehrheit der exoplaneten geht auf sein konto
2500 stück der absolute wahnsinn
jetzt aber noch
Getoppt wird es hat nämlich deutlich verbesserte leistungsdaten und eine veränderte mission zum einen
Sucht nicht kleine ausschnitte des himmels ab sondern hat eine
350 mal größer
Beobachtungs fläche als keppler das alte weltraumteleskop suchte den himmel ja stück für stück ab und dabei ist das ja alles wirklich ein
Wenig verblüffend dass das exo planeten gibt das wissen wir erst seit den 90er jahren vorher gab es keine methoden um sie aufzuspüren
Mit der entdeckung von drei planeten die um den puls aps r 12 57 +12
kreisen durch den polnischen astronomen alexander wolf wurde das 1992 anlass der pulsa pulse nämlich
unregelmäßig da planeten sein strahlt blockierten durch die genaue bestimmung dieser unregelmäßigkeiten
konnten drei planeten entdeckt werden das waren damit die ersten planeten die zweifelsfrei existierten und
1995 wurde dann der erste planet entdeckt er um einen stern ähnlich unserer sonne kreist planet 51 pegasi b
Kreis, um einen stern
Im sternbild pegasus seine entdecker hatten festgestellt dass der stern 51 pegasi im all herum feiert
verursacht durch einen planeten der um ihn kreist anhand der stärke dieses 1 konnten sie sogar die größe des planeten errechnen
0,46 jupitermassen so langsam kamen die planeten suche in fahrt jetzt ging es darum planeten aufzuspüren die erd- ähnlich sind und
Damit leben ermöglichen das war wie die nadel. Im heuhaufen zu suchen die meisten planeten waren zu heiß zu kalt
Zu klein zu groß es gab kein wasser auf ihn oder sie kreisten
zudem
zentral gestellt doch in den letzten jahren wurden immer mehr planeten
entdeckt und damit auch immer mehr auf denen leben möglich ist eine bedingung ist ja die entfernung der
Planeten zum stern. Um den sieg reisen sie müssen sie in der goldlöckchen
Zone die heißt tatsächlich so der habitablen zone befinden benannt ist diese zone
Nach dem märchen über das goldlöckchen das erst zu heißen brei ist dann
Zu kalten und dann breit er richtig temperiert ist denn das ist die wichtigste bedingung es darf auf dem planeten nicht
So heiß und nicht
Zu kalt sein damit leben entstehen kann aber es gibt planeten auf denen diese bedingungen gelten und auf denen sogar
Ausreichend wasser vorhanden ist doch das sind nur sehr wenige dies 12 14 b ist einer von, ihnen und vielleicht
derjenige mit den besten bekannten lebensbedingungen
er hat den richtigen abstand zum zentralgestirn einem roten zwerg einem kleinen nicht sehr heißen stern und blies 12 14 b verfügt über eine atmosphäre
Mit einer menge wasserdampf hier sind die chancen. Am größten dass es leben dort
Existieren könnte allerdings ist mit 12 14 rund 40 lichtjahre von uns entfernt für uns zur zeit
Unerreichbar ja und es wurden ja immer mehr solcher planeten entdeckt zuletzt das treppchen
system mit sogar sieben exoplaneten von denen drei in der habitablen zone liegen mit heutigen stand sind
Exoplaneten entdeckt worden und mit tests soll diese zahl deutlich, höher werden es wird
200.000 sterne untersuchen die möglichst nah an der erde liegen und wird so
Mit dem transit verfahren besser schneller und damit wahrscheinlich viel mehr
Exoplaneten finden bei diesem verfahren wird ja untersucht ob und wie stark und wie regelmäßig
Sternen sich verdunkeln daraus kann ganz einfach errechnet werden wie groß und in welcher entfernung um die welcher geschwindigkeit
planeten an den jeweiligen sternen vorbeizieht und damit auch in abhängigkeit von der stern klasse und der größe des
zentralgestirns ob sie in der habitablen
Zone liegen und damit leben auf ihnen existieren könnte und das geht jetzt ganz schnell los in zwei monaten ist es auf position und dann
Startet die mission die es zunächst auf zwei jahre begrenzt bis dann hoffentlich endlich der x-fach verschobene start des james webb, weltraumteleskop
Stattfindet dann geht es nämlich wirklich ab und wir haben eine
riesen-chance
Spuren von leben zu finden wenn er als erstes neues zum thema alien suche und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert und so brüssel
ich noch ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
außerirdisches leben an viel mehr orten möglich da geht es um die these dass sie vielleicht nicht unbedingt in der habitablen
zone liegen müssen also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran